i guess my my biggest thing becomes
if if there's a bigger push to go
private then go public because
the challenge becomes there is zero
competition for cia you have a monopoly
there's zero competition for fbi you
have a monopoly that is not good there's
a reason why we have monopoly laws when
a t went through it microsoft went to
went through it you know even facebook
right now is going through hey we got to
kind of break it apart you're two this
you're too that okay i actually
understand some of those conversations
but
why have monopoly loss for free
enterprise and not have monopoly laws
for government agencies i think we need
monopoly laws for government agencies
how does a patent differ from
a monopoly
patent gives you a timeline you don't
have it forever correct okay right
monopolies don't last for either forever
either they incentivize people to create
competition and monopolies are
intentionally
attacked by the federal government where
patents are protected by the federal
government sure so what i'm saying is
that there's a place for everything
there's a place for patents there's a
place for monopoly there's a place for
secret intelligence services there's a
place for one-sided advantage absolutely
but there should be checks and balances
there are checks and balances in our in
our private intelligence world and our
secret intelligence world publicly and
privately
but what we're also finding is that
there's vulnerabilities that nobody
talks about the vast majority of
espionage cases right now are coming
from private intelligence
they're coming from chinese russian
iranian
penetrations through the private
intelligence network into a mainstream
building we just there was just two a
husband and wife couple i don't know if
you want to look it up husband and wife
couple that were working that were
teachers
in i don't know where it was somewhere
in the northeast but they were caught
spying giving nuclear secrets about
american submarine technology to an
unnamed foreign service they were just
arrested because they were contracted
the husband was contracted as a as an
engineer to go
to go work with the navy and now
because of that in maryland thank you
very much
this just happened nobody knows this
happened this doesn't make headlines
this is the kind of stuff where where
we're doing the right thing and nobody
even knows it's happening this happens
all the time unpack the story so what
happened here maryland husband and wife
arrested a nuclear submarine spy case
the couple are accused of selling
nuclear secrets including a sd card
concealed in a peanut butter sandwich
this is classic human intelligence
espionage i would i would suspect that
this that the unnamed service that
they're talking about here is the
chinese because this fits a chinese
model of collecting military secrets on
american technology
right down to the fact that they were
doing dead drops in maryland in food
but let's let's break that down a little
bit because i think you could make the
case that even though it may be a
private institution it's still
technically controlled by the ccp right
and i think
it's because it's tied to the chinese
government i think you could make the
same case for russia and i i don't
disagree with pat on the idea that we
should privatize
uh uh intelligence agencies but i think
you mentioned raytheon so like how do we
keep if we do go that route how do we
keep from raytheon making up false
intelligence to sell weapons right or
like going down that path to where
they're they're no longer focused on the
actual intelligence they're focused on
the bottom line of the profit well
that's one of the reasons that you want
to have a national intelligence
organization because one of the ways
that you differentiate information from
intelligence is through a process called
betting information can be single source
one time you hear it you can't find it
anywhere else vetting means you have to
find the same piece of information in
multiple different unrelated sources
right so the difference between
information intelligence is specific but
what i'm saying here is this penetration
these secrets were lost because of the
privatization of of intelligence had
this been a naval engineer working only
within the navy it would have been
harder
for a foreign intelligence service to
recruit them and get them to provide
secrets but because this person was a
civilian working for a private
organization contracted by the navy it
was easier so you're saying there's more
risk to being privatized there's more
risk to being privatized just like
there's more risk to any company hiring
anybody like how do you know if you work
in the number one company in
pharmaceuticals that the number two
company in pharmaceuticals doesn't
recruit your top sales so so let me tell
you this i fully fully agree between
what you're saying fully agree with what
you're saying however there's a big
however
so
there there is risk to both sides it's
which risk you want more so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
you